all in the green room and guys it's a
social distance broadcast and we're
going to have fun
big game james i know it's just a
scrimmage but you
me laker fans we don't care we're beyond
elated to be back yeah yeah the fans and
you know just about everybody in america
uh needs
offense properly defense properly you're
looking to see just
how quickly they can get in sync and and
and do what the coaches have actually do
he's at 45
from three second best in the nba behind
george hill
and 18. you're really not looking into
the crowd maybe there's a free throw or
something like that
so the sound should sound real and
a little familiar to them hopefully
nuggets versus dallas beaubon went for
31-17
porzingis did not play that game he was
resting his sorney so bobon absolutely
can get it done as kcp does a nice job
getting in the lane
and throwing it up there's kcp getting
into the lane and he's gotten better at
that this years are gonna
have to think about more as they get
into the postseason whether that's
against dallas or
uh some of the other opponents that can
go small in that sense by having a
big out on the perimeter small of course
a.d sliding over
and porzingis with his fourth personal
went to the bench and lebron
attacked the pain well i'd like to see
the game get back a little bit
to where you could you know tag him a
little bit lebron james taking advantage
of the mismatch with jackson goes right
to the hoop
finishes with the left it's 42-34 lakers
[Applause]
lebron doing a nice job oh nice give and
go but it's
intercepted lakers doing a nice job
getting their hands on the passing lane
dwight howard
up top bang
last break points and here's why lebron
james